wir haben ja eben darüber gesprochen
dass es ganz enorm wichtig ist jetzt vom
russischen gas wegzukommen von der
abhängigkeit vom russischen gas und da
müssen wir einfach die realität
anerkennen und da muss auch die
bundesregierung und insbesondere die
grünen weg kommen von ihrer
ideologischen fundamental verweigerung
gegenüber der kernenergie wir haben wir
erleben in allen ländern um uns herum in
polen in den niederlanden in frankreich
oder großbritannien das neue
kernkraftwerke gebaut werden in schweden
oder italien wird der ausstieg aus dem
ausstieg diskutiert deutschland ist in
der frage der kernkraft inzwischen der
geisterfahrer in europa der glaubt alle
anderen würden in die falsche richtung
fahren und deswegen ist es jetzt an der
zeit im übrigen auch angesichts der
zweiten großen krise die wir haben und
das ist der klimawandel wir müssen den
co2 ausstoß weiter verringern wir
brauchen mehr elektrizität etwa für
elektroautos und das zusammenzubringen
das geht eben am ende technisch nur mit
der kernenergie ja wir müssen auch die
erneuerbaren energien weiter ausbauen
aber diese unabhängigkeit ist ganz ganz
wichtig und im übrigen ist auch das
argument von vblock dagegen überhaupt
nicht tragfähig dass sie sagt auch bei
den urahn lieferungen werden wir von
russland abhängig denn zweitgrößter
ölexporteur der welt ist kanada es gibt
richter rousseff auf platz zehn oder
sowas selbst in deutschland gibt es an
vorkommen also dieses argument trägt
nicht die bundesregierung insbesondere
die grünen müssen weg von ihrem anti
kernkraft dogma damit wir unabhängig
werden können vom russischen gas
was wenn sie dazu sagen ja es wird herrn
heißt vielleicht überraschen aber ich
gebe ihnen der vollständig recht
es ist eine forderung die ich selber
seit langem erhebe ich beschäftige mich
wie die energiepolitik tiefer der
kardinalfehler der gemacht wurde in
unserer energieversorgung den hat angela
merkel 2011 mit dem ausstieg aus der
kernenergie gemacht der überhastet war
der falsch war und der uns in die
abhängigkeit hineingebracht hat die wir
heute mit recht beklagen das ist das
fatale nun haben wir einen kernkraftwerk
nach dem anderen abgeschaltet wir haben
im moment noch drei im netz ich habe in
ihrem statement gelesen sie wollten auch
welche die schon vom netz gegangen sind
wieder ans netz holen das wird nicht
funktionieren das kann ich ihnen sagen
sie mal mit den ingenieuren die sich
darauf verstehen mit den
energieanbietern das geht nicht aber es
ist bedauerlich dass das geschehen ist
grundsätzlich aber ist die position die
sie haben völlig richtig wenn wir eine
unabhängigkeit haben wollen und wir
brauchen grundlastfähigen energie das
liefern wind und solarenergie nicht dann
kommen wir um moderne nutzung der
kernenergie nicht herum und das sind
keine steinzeit reaktoren mehr wie anno
dunnemals sondern die reaktoren der
vierten generation sind sehr sicher und
deswegen sollte man tatsächlich darauf
setzen auf diese technologie nicht
verzichten so dass wir einen
ideologiefreien dass das was sie mit
recht monieren wir haben eine völlig
ideologie geleitete energiepolitik
insbesondere betrieben von grün wir
brauchen eine ideologiefreie
positionierung dazu und dann werden wir
einen energiemix bekommen in dem die
kernenergie und zwar in moderner form
ebenso vorkommt wie wie
selbstverständlich auch erneuerbare
energien
also ich hab das ja also musst du auch
nicht gesagt ich sage mal wenn wir über
neue reaktoren reden würden dann würden
wir auch über technische innovationen
reden müssen und dennoch ja auch weil
natürlich dass im sinne auch der
nachhaltigkeit das problem der endlager
endlagerung natürlich ein anderes ist
bei modernen reaktoren die noch dann
sehr schnell auch endlich aber noch
wiederverwenden können insofern glaube
ich ja ist das einfach wichtig dass wir
damit kommen ist ist ja insgesamt auch
eine frage der technologieoffenheit ich
meine selbst die fdp ist jetzt ja
umgekippt und hat plötzlich gesagt ja
beim auto legen wir uns fest auf die
batterie auch das ist ja glaube ich so
schnell denn genau das ist nicht die
aufgabe von politikern das zu
entscheiden sondern dafür haben einen
freien markt der eben relativ gut darin
ist am ende auch gewinner auszuwählen
und verlierer auszuwählen und das
sollten die politiker tun insofern ich
würde das nicht ganz teilen was sie
gesagt haben das war ein anderer kontext
ich glaube schon dass wir jetzt noch mal
gucken müssen und das hat mir neue
bedeutung bekommen wie werden wir
unabhängig vom russischen gas ohne
massiv unseren co2 ausstoß etwa mit
kohle die ansonsten eine alternative
wäre zu erhöhen ich glaube da sind wir
nicht mehr einer meinung ich habe
gelesen jedenfalls dass sie dem den
menschengemachten klimawandel nicht für
eine realität halten das sehe ich anders
und ich habe das ist es auch anderes
gelesen das ist ganz ganz wichtig immer
besser das ist ganz ganz wichtig ist
dass das können sie ja korrigieren aber
ich glaube das ist ganz ganz wichtig ist
dass wir eben dieses ziel auch nicht aus
den augen verlieren und das ausgerechnet
jetzt die grünen ich meine die absurde
sache ist ja im grunde genommen ist
keine deutsche partei für mehr co2
ausstoß in deutschland verantwortlich
als die grünen mit ihrem jahrzehntelang
irrational und unwissenschaftlichen
kampf gegen die kernenergie das ist eine
ironie ein stück weiter geschichte aber
da können wir ja eben dazu lernen und
die finnischen grünen übrigens sehen
dass er anders die sind nämlich sehr
pragmatisch und realistisch die begrüßen
ausdrücklich die nutzung der kernenergie
in finnland und auch das betreiben einer
endlagerstätte die haben wir eine völlig
andere herangehensweise
und tatsächlich ist das grüne als das
was die deutschen grünen uns hier als
grün verkaufen das ist tatsächlich so da
müssen wir uns an dieser stelle nicht
auch in der runde ehrlich machen das
wirklich sagen wir sollen zurück zur
atomenergie und so weiter aber müssen
wir nicht auch ganz klar sagen es ist
jetzt nicht von heute auf morgen möglich
so wie sollen wir jetzt gerade agieren
und man muss ja klar sagen wenn wir
jetzt zum beispiel die importe von öl
sofort kappen amerika wird sich schon
auch darüber freuen weil die ölindustrie
ist dort sehr sehr stark ist ein
steigender ölpreis ist wird ja dann
steigen also die menschen werden
einnahmen haben und putin kann ja auch
weiter nach china verkaufen wenn der
ölpreis seien auch weiter steigt wird
das kompensiert deswegen meine frage in
die runde wie sollen wir uns denn jetzt
gerade verhalten weil es hört sich
natürlich alles richtig an und wir
müssen auch agieren aber werden wir dann
auch alle mit damit leben wollen und das
auch wirklich dafür tun für die ukraine
zum beispiel sie heißen würden sie dann
auch sagen kein problem ich verzichte
auf strom wenn die wohnung kälter wird
es mir auch egal also etwas pathetisch
jetzt auf das ich habe letztens den
schönen spruch gesehen spule stadt putin
da ist natürlich was dran aber es ist
glaube ich auch naiv zu glauben mit mit
mit individuell maßnahmen allein würde
man zurechtkommen aber natürlich ist das
ein richtiger maßstab im moment übrigens
geht es erstmal darum die drei noch
laufenden kernreaktoren nicht einfach
abzuschalten die sind die funktionieren
ja dass das klappt ja alles also so aber
insofern ich bin völlig bei herrn klaus
natürlich das was in der ukraine
verteidigt wird das ist auch unser
europa ist auch unsere freiheit es sind
auch unsere werte und deswegen es wird
am ende nicht gehen ohne dass wir auch
in irgendeiner form mindestens
wohlstands einbußen hinnehmen natürlich
müssen wir dann darauf achten durch
steuersenkung gerade es kann nicht sein
dass der staat noch an steigenden
benzinpreis ich versehen oder eine
wohngeld erhöhung oder was auch immer es
dafür maßnahmen gibt damit hier niemand
unter die räder kommt aber natürlich es
wird am ende wenn wir sagen wir müssen
für unsere werte kämpfen ansonsten haben
wir das problem dass die ukraine hat
womöglich irgendwann auch hier
so diese realität dass wir anerkennen
und und vielleicht noch ein letzter satz
die sind diesen appell an den realismus
den herrn ausgerichtet hat den müssen
wir auch mit blick auf china und
uns zu eigen machen denn das ist ja die
nächste frage und china wird sich genau
ansehen wie geht europa wie geht der
westen mit putin um nachdem er die
ukraine überfall nicht also er heißt da
wird es schon mal für den frieden und
auch für die ukraine frieren wie sieht
es bei ihnen aus arbeiten schon weit
würden sie gehen wir werden wir werden
opfer dafür bringen müssen und die
werden auch individuell zu erbringen
seien das ist sicherlich so welche opfer
würden sie selbst bringen
wir bringen im moment bereits opfer in
form der der massiven verteuerung der
preise die wir haben ich habe heute früh
um einen öltank zuhause aufgefüllt ich
habe öl bereits das haus und die haben
ja gesagt das ist doppelt so teuer wie
beim letzten mal so dass geht betrifft
mich das betrifft viele andere und ich
mache mir große sorgen um die anderen
nicht um mich selbst weil das natürlich
eine soziale komponente hat und es ist
tatsächlich so dass wir im energiesektor
eine volle mehrwertsteuer da drauf haben
da muss man vielleicht mal an die frage
herangehen als bundesregierung wenn
wirklich menschen das sind nicht mal
sozial schwache das sind ganz normale
familien mit kindern die können sich das
nicht mehr leisten ich habe mein
einkommen ich kann das kann das bezahlen
gefällt mir auch nicht aber das ist
nicht das problem aber wir kommen in die
situation rein wo menschen familien alte
menschen in ungeheizten wohnungen sitzen
und das wollen wir nicht und das können
wir natürlich auch machen mit einem
einfluss auf die preise denn wenn sie
sich die energiepreise mal anschauen und
sie schauen sich den anteil staatlicher
abgaben daran an also exemplarisch beim
liter beim liter diesel den man tankt
haben wir 70 prozent staatliche abgaben
30 prozent ist der warenwert der staat
hat eine menge machen und wir müssen in
dieser situation denen die das nicht
mitgehen können helfen weil das wirklich
und das sind nicht nur dass sie nicht
nur sozial schwache das sind das eine
ganz normale familien mittelklasse
einkommen die zur arbeit fahren müssen
und das trifft die hart und da müssen
wir ran und wie heißt hier die
bundesregierung die bundesregierung
steht in der verantwortung
zum beispiel mit der mehrwertsteuer
runterzugehen das übrigens auch im
brüsseler problem das muss aus brüssel
nämlich genehmigt werden ich habe das
gerade gestern in einer rede im
europäischen parlament so aufgefordert
wobei wir zum beispiel an die
mineralölsteuern auf jeden fall meine
ich ran können und auch mit der
mehrwertsteuer hat sich jetzt auch schon
wieder was gegenteil also auch das ist
zumindest rechtlich ist das aus meiner
sicht recht eigenständig machen kann
aber ich möchte mal sagen ihr seid ja
nicht darum jetzt irgendwie die
staatsausgaben enorm zu erhöhen sondern
es geht einfach darum die mehreinnahmen
die der staat ja hat der deutschland
profitiert von den steigenden
energiepreisen im moment die mindestens
zurückzugeben und insofern glaube ich
ist das unbedingt angezeigt dass wir da
steuersenkungen an und ich glaube was
was auch klar ist und das ist sollte
eigentlich auch jens der ideologie
stehen ist dass der ausbau von
erneuerbarer energie oder ist enormes
potenzial immer noch da dass der nicht
nur für deutschland selbst sondern auch
in der deutschen außenpolitik eine rolle
spielen sollte wo ist das deutsche
konzept das europäische konzept auch in
anderen in der nachbarregion mit
tunesien da gibt es sehr viele ich bin
jetzt wirklich kein experte dafür ich
lese was experten sagen aber da gibt es
viel potenzial für partnerschaft mit
sonnen mit solarenergie mit der türkei
deren abhängigkeit zu reduzieren von
dass das importiert wird autoritären
staaten was die türkei auch als
nato-partner abhängig macht von
problemen wie wir sehen in dieser
jetzigen krise das ist wichtig ist im
schwarzen meer auch verbündete zu haben
wie schaffen wir es in polen zb immer
noch große abhängigkeit vom von extrem
schmutziger kohle die aus russland
importiert wird also selbst polen das
eine sehr starke aus der geschichte
vollkommen nicht nur verständlich
sondern rationale
opposition gegenüber russland immer
hatte und irgendwie hätten mehr auf die
polen hören müssen in dieser frage ist
im energiebereich durch die kohle
importiert so stand am abhängig ich
glaube diese idee den klimawandel der
real ist wo wir reagieren müssen weil
sonst kommen ganz andere kosten auf uns
zu und und die außenpolitik und das
strategische die unabhängigkeit von
autokratien zusammenzudenken europäisch
und da war das problem natürlich es war
zu bequem die letzten jahre ich werde
mich noch vor kurzem der gaspreis war
sehr war unglaublich niedrig war es vor
einem jahr zwei jahre und der diskurs
war wir bauen da pipelines es gibt
schiefergas wir haben rohstoffe wer das
ganze wurde es wurde viel geld gemacht
in diesem bereich und jetzt stellt sich
heraus dass sowohl strategisch als auch
natürlich von der perspektive von co2
und und und dem umbau für ein
klimafreundliches wirtschaftssystem dass
diese bequemlichkeit auch fatal ist